Hi everyone. Sean Spitzer, Senior Instructor for Epic Games.
We're going to go to the next slide here.
And in here, we're going to create the image to embody a 3D LUT, and we're going to talk about how LUTs work.
So, to create the image to embody a 3D LUT, the size of the LUT data must be known.
For this example, we assume that the LUT is 33 by 33, by 33.
So the size equals 33, and the image dimension should be a width and size.
So we're kind of imitating a cube.
The arrangement of the pixel values must follow a specific pattern.
This is really important.
And the above image shows a 1089 by 33 image.
Now, older versions of LUTs.
We have an older version. Let's go to Unreal Engine for a second.
There's an old way to do LUTs, and you'll find that within your post-process volume.
So, you'll notice some of the older color LUTs here, underneath our miscellaneous.
You'll notice there's a LUT here.
Should you load your LUT here?
No, unless you're working for mobile.
Having mobile devices, or maybe even a low-end iPad, I mean really low.
You can actually do that.
But it's going to smash your color down.
It's going to make your resolution poor.
So, in an ICV effect scenario, we want to be able to actually work with LUTs with a higher resolution.
So we're going to ignore the miscellaneous area where we load them,
and we're going to be loading ours underneath Rendering,
and we're going to be loading them within our post-process material here.
This is what we want, and we're going to be working with a high-resolution image for that.
Let's go back to the slides for a moment.
So, what we're doing, and let me explain this so it's clear, because this can be a little bit confusing for people.
OCIOs, believe it or not, are still 3D LUTs, because we're putting it within this 3D space.
They're coded so that they can actually make sense within this real-time environment.
What we're going to do is grab an OpenEXR image file,
and we're going to get that, and we're going to make it so that you can use whatever software you're familiar with.
You can use Nuke, you can use Premiere, you can grab an image from Unreal and take it into there,
and make them and output them to be an EXR HDR.
So, to make the LUT interesting, each of these values must contain the desired output of the 3D LUT.
So we're going to be using our material nodes to be able to get this to work.
Regularly, by using an image processing program that supports your desired LUT,
and I said you can use any one that you want, you can produce these OpenEXRs.
That's really what we need to be able to actually take this into our material.
So we're going to be taking this object, this image, this LUT, this converted desired colored output,
and we're going to be going to edit ours in Unreal so that we can actually have it understand our environment.
Now, I give you code here in our slides, let's go to the next one,
I give you code here in our slides that allow you to use this code in Nuke,
and you can actually place this inside of Nuke and grab the image that you need,
and this will help you build the node system.
Now, we don't do this in this particular class, but I do provide this code for you.
Now, be careful when you're cutting and pasting, this is coming from like a PDF document,
or it's coming from a PowerPoint, there we go,
you're grabbing it from PowerPoint, and it may not format correctly,
so just keep that in mind, there may be some tweaking you have to do because of the formatting.
But this will actually get you in the right direction.
So let's go ahead in Unreal, we're going to now build what you see on the screen.
We're going to build a 3D LUT and start building the nodes for it,
and I'm going to explain to you what's happening under the hood.
So we have a 3D LUT samples here, this is one that was made by one of my coworkers here,
she took it into Nuke and did some tweaking,
and I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to right click,
and what I want to do is create and convert this particular texture and bend it to my will.
So we want to be able to actually create a thing called a volume texture.
So you'll see that right here, create volume texture.
So let's go and create one, let's give it a new name,
I'll just put new so I don't mix them up at all.
I'm going to double click on it, and you'll notice automatically
that it doesn't quite look the same as the one that we have below.
It's nice and smooth and seems to be in the right direction.
So what we need to do is actually set our points correctly here,
and let me show you how that works.
So in the X category here of our tile, we want to set that to 33,
and hit enter, because we want to get this to be a cube.
We want our tile size to be 33 here too.
Now if you get band size, don't worry about it,
it's okay and this is still being digested correctly.
One of the most important things we want to do is control our compression.
We want to make sure that we're not getting any kind of compression on this.
So we want to make sure we have HDR set in here with no sRGB.
People get kind of hung up with Unreal, not realizing,
sRGB and linear, so we set up Unreal so that you can use this for film.
It uses the linear ACES color management system.
So you're okay and you're on the right track when you set these settings,
so don't let it mess with your head.
Unreal does it quite well, and you can actually get some amazing results.
So now that we set those in here, we're going to hit save.
We're going to save that for that particular volume that we made.
So again, if you missed that, I right clicked on the 3D LUT
and I went in here and said creative volume texture.
Once that was created, I went in here and I adjusted the size
and I made sure that it was producing an HDR, no compression.
Now let's go ahead and go back to the slides.
Now again, you'll see that sample set up here and explaining what's going on.
So what we want to do now is we want to build the nodes
within a material and we want to make that material
so that we can go in here and edit things the way that we need.
So let's go and do that.
So let's go back to Unreal.
So in Unreal, I'm going to go ahead and make a new material.
I'm going to go to material here and we'll call this M underscore 3D LUT in class.
I'm going to double click on this material.
I want to make sure that this material is going to be able to be used
with a post-process volume.
So let me go full screen here for a second so you can see everything.
I'll leave my stats up.
They'll actually pop up if anything bad goes on.
But actually, no, let's go ahead and close that.
It'll give us a bit more real estate.
So what we want to do is go underneath our surfaces here,
underneath our details for this material,
and we want to set this to a post-process volume.
Really important to get that going
because what's going to happen with that?
It's going to allow us to be able to now be used
or use this material in a post-process setting.
Unreal will know our intentions.
One of the first things you need to do when you're doing that
is we want to create a scene texture.
So I'm going to go ahead and type in scene texture.
Click on that.
I now need to change its scene ID.
So I'm going to click on scene color ID.
This basically is telling Unreal, giving it a little bit more information
on what our intentions are and what we want to use it for.
In our case, we want to use it for a post-process input 0.
So if you're familiar with Blueprints,
what we're about to do is going to be very similar.
We have this initial information of our intentions,
but we want to be able to break information from Unreal
and remake it to what we want.
Now, if you're familiar with Blueprints,
you can break your data and you can rebuild your data.
And that's kind of what we're going to do here.
We're going to use a thing called break out float for components.
So let's type in break out for components there.
And I'm going to grab the color information
and pull that string into that float for.
So we've now kind of exposed the control for RGB.
And in Unreal, in this particular scenario specifically,
that RGB, we now want to make that translated into an XYZ.
We want to make that same, these three colors
to be able to be identified in a 3D space.
So we've now broke, we broke this information.
You can think of it that way, really just kind of exposed it.
And we're now going to make a float three.
Make float three.
And you'll see the XYZ available here.
And we're going to pull these strings across.
RGB, XYZ.
Really nice.
So what we have here is we've now made it
so we've exposed this information.
We want to be able to now edit that information
and we want to do it efficiently.
So if we go back to it, again, I'm going to comment these.
I'm going to put the C here.
And I'm going to say input to use for our post process volume material.
You can say intentions.
You can kind of think of it that way.
Hopefully my typing is not going to fail me here.
A second, so you know exactly what's going on.
I'm putting active notes here.
This is going to be allows and breaks
and restructures for LUT 3D data.
Allows us to break and reconstruct
or restructure for LUT 3D data.
And I'll change that color so it's a little bit closer to my notes-ish
if you're following along.
And again, you can use my notes as I do this
so you can actually understand what's going on.
So what we need to do is now bring in the math information
because this is all nice and dandy,
but Unreal doesn't know what kind of rows we have,
what are we adjusting, what is the math under the hood.
So the input texture will have a specific size.
In this case, it's like we said earlier,
it's 33 by 33 by 33 pixels.
So the value that is labeled 32, 33,
which is this value we're going to make.
I'm going to keep my finger on the S key for a scalar parameter.
And if you wanted to, you can make it a constant.
In my example, it's actually a constant.
So we can do that.
So you're not getting confused.
Let me keep my finger on the one key, left click,
and we can rename this sucker.
So we can go to our comments here and call this 32 over 33.
This is the fraction of n minus 1 over n.
So if we go to the slides for a moment,
you'll see that information here.
So the value labeled 32, 33 is the fraction of parentheses
n minus 1 over n, where n is the size of a LUT,
and the other value is 0.5 over n.
So we're basically trying to get it so we can adjust things.
The reason they are needed is to give the texture sampling to work properly.
So we're trying to get the texture sampling to go in the right direction.
Let's go back to Unreal.
So we have the first one set up,
but let's actually put the right numbers in here.
So the number we need for this particular one is 0.9697.
And that's going to give our data the correct input.
And that string is going to go into our B channel.
So let's put this into our B channel of a multiply.
So we've got to be able to have a multiply here.
And you can build it ahead of time or do what I did where I just called it up.
The hotkey for that is M,
just a reminder for those that haven't touched materials for a while.
Oh, looks like I put it in the A channel.
So let's go and remove that and reroute it.
So I'm going to keep my finger on the control left click and reroute that right into the B channel
so I'm following my own advice.
I'm going to grab that make float and put it into the A channel there.
And let's go ahead.
Now we also need to make another math node like we mentioned before.
We're going to get that 0 over 33 or I should say 0.5 over 33.
So let's go and do that.
And we keep a finger on the one key.
Click again. I keep misclicking my bad.
Let's give it a comma here.
So this is the 0 5 over 33 equaling, so it makes sense to you, 0.5 slash n.
And you'll find that again in my notes.
And let's change that number there too.
So that number in this particular case needs to be 0.01515.
And we now need to run that into an add.
We're basically trying to control our rows and placement.
So let me go and get the add node up.
So I'm going to hit my finger on the A key, left click, get the add.
Let me move the final execution here of our material over a bit.
So give yourself some room.
I'm going to grab that multiply node, pull the string and go into my A channel.
I'm going to grab this string of this particular node and pull this into my B channel.
All right.
So now what we need to do is we need to create a parameter, a param volume.
So let's go and get that up.
And we're doing a search for it.
So we got a texture, sample parameter volume.
That's what we need.
And you'll see the abbreviation of it, Unreal, how it abbreviates it.
It's called a param volume.
You literally can type in param volume.
And I'm going to call this my apply 3D LUT.
We'll call this new, just so we can keep track of it.
And I'm going to now grab that add and pull it into my UVs.
Now you'll notice when you make this,
you're going to get a generic engine texture volume under here in the details of this param volume.
We need to swap that out.
We need to actually grab the one that we just made.
So to be able to grab it, you just remember what it's called.
Let's go and drag this over for a second here.
3D LUT, it has a new within the name.
So let's just type in 3D LUT new.
There it is.
And now we have the right one in place.
And now I'm going to grab the RGB string, pull it into my emissive.
See, it's purple world everywhere, space purple planet.
They're initially in my material.
Let me go and hit save.
Probably should have just hit apply so I can use this for another class.
So let's go ahead and apply it to our scene.
I'm going to minimize my material.
And I'm going to go to my post process volume that I already have enabled.
In this particular one, I have it set up.
So it is, I believe, infinite extended bound, and that's fine.
We're not working with lumen in this particular case.
I don't have the settings on a very strenuous setup here.
Let's go to render where we'll find our post process volume material.
I went too far.
Let me close some of these.
Not needed.
There we go.
It's very small.
It's easy to scroll past it.
I'm going to click on the plus here.
Go to asset reference.
And now I can drag that right into that material.
And we have purple space planet, island of purple-ness.
I got nothing.
All right.
So let's go back to the slides here and talk about some pro tips involved when it comes to your 3D LUTs.
And then finally, let's take a look at this real quick.
So pro tips.
Ensure that the same viewport or node is not included in multiple OSAO overrides.
And you heard me talk about that.
So you can easily stack this if you're not paying attention on accident.
You can end up loading a color profile like we did in a post process volume over a 3D LUT.
You can end up loading this in your end display.
You can end up having it in the camera itself.
So you've got to be careful.
You have to make sure that you know where everything's at.
So you're not accidentally overriding or tweaking your color information unnecessarily.
Additionally, color grading can be applied with the end display, which we mentioned,
and is the preferred way to go, especially in 5.0.
And that may evolve to a higher level later on with new versions of Unreal.
So in shuffling your color work, like we mentioned,
keep in mind how the color changes based on the order of operation.
So set your post process volume for optimal output to tone curve amount to zero.
Your expand gamut to zero.
Your blue correction to zero.
Your chromatic aberration to zero.
And vignetting to zero.
And bluing to zero.
Those are just good practices.
And you can leave those on.
And that allows you, if you needed to go edit them later for any particular reason,
they're available and they're ready to go.
So again, how this is approached processing wise.
And I keep mentioning this because it's really good to understand how this works.
So color processing happens in this order based on your approach.
Lighting to produce scene color.
Post process material before tone mapper.
Tone mapper, which includes the tone curve and bloom and vignette,
or replace tone mapper.
OCIO, which turns off the tone curve if replace tone mapper is not used.
And again, post process material after tone mapper.
So this is basically the order of how things can interrupt with each other.
So think of it that way.
So if you don't consider this order, you actually can't overwrite your stuff.
This is how things are processed.
So think of it that way on my list here.
I hope all of you enjoyed this course.
And feel free to let us know if you have any other questions.